So, cut to now.
We have... still have an energy crisis...
...and now, we have a climate crisis as well.
You know, so, humans generate about 12 trillion watts or 12 terawatts from fossil fuels...
...and Al Gore has spoken to why we need to hit one of these targets,...
...and in reality, what that means is in the next 30 to 40 years,...
...we have to make ten trillion watts or more of new clean energy, somehow.
Wind is the second largest renewable resource after solar: 3600 terawatts,...
...more than enough to supply humanity 200 times over.
The majority of it is in the higher altitudes, above 300 feet,...
...where we don't have the technology as yet to get there.
So, this is the dawn of the new age of kites.
This is our test site on Maui, flying across the sky.
I'm now going to show you the first autonomous generation of power...
...by every child's favorite plaything.
As you can tell, you need to be a robot to fly this thing for thousands of hours.
It makes you a little nauseous.
And here we're actually generating about 10 kilowatts,...
...so enough to power probably five United States households,...
...with a kite not much larger than this piano.
And the real significant thing here is we're developing the control systems, as did the Wright brothers,...
...that would enable sustained, long duration flight.
And it doesn't hurt to do it in a location like this either.